[Música]
[Aplausos]
el gusto cuida la vida de su bestia más
el corazón de los impíos es cruel
proverbios 12 10 los ojos dulces de un
perro y las travesuras de un gato nos
aportan alegría y hace que su
convivencia nos mejora en nuestro estado
de físico y mental e incluso prolonga la
vida
acariciarlos reduce la presión arterial
ayuda a la recuperación de enfermedades
y muchas veces a la recuperación de
traumas personales como la pérdida de un
ser querido o el cambio de un estilo de
vida deplorable a una placentera y feliz
pero la realidad es otra en cada país
año tras año aumenta el número de
abandono y maltrato este dato es
preocupante y para disminuir estas
cifras se precisa de la mayor
intervención y cooperación de todos el
abandono no entiende ni razas y edades
determinadas
las principales causas del abandono son
comportamiento animal
factores económicos camadas inesperadas
y cambio de domicilio podemos hacer algo
para mejorar esto claro que sí
para que el abandono deje de ser un
problema podemos
y tomar las siguientes medidas número 1
educando
con la ayuda de un entrenador o un
etólogo que es un psicólogo animal
número 2 esterilizando
informándote sobre ese proceso con un
veterinario o una fundación de
protección animal número 3 identificando
a nuestra mascota con su plaquita o chip
para poder recuperar número 4
reflexionando antes de tener un animal
de compañía por todo lo que conlleva
número 5 adoptando un animal rescatado
para darle una segunda oportunidad
si un hombre aspira a llevar una vida
correcta su primer acto de abstinencia
es no dañar a los animales leo tolstóy
si ves un animal abandonado o maltratado
se su voz ayudarlo no lo dejes solo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]